Hi, Dr. Connors. Any advice for sudden itchy skin rashes appearing on a couple of different parts of the body?
Looking something like possible psoriasis on one part, it's still there after three months,
turning more red and now covered in larger area. One natural suggestion was aloe vera. Thanks for your input.
Yeah, well, you do want to try to figure out what the cause of this is because you have different causes for different rashes.
If it is psoriasis, then that ties to autoimmune issues. If it's more of a simple contact or a tightest, which can last for a long period of time,
at different times, especially when you haven't figured out the thing that you're reacting to that is that you've covered contact with.
So, if you're always, whenever you have rashes, you want to try to get a diagnosis. There's different virus and different fungi, different bacteria that can cause rashes, especially in childhood rashes, very common.
You could go on Google and search for pictures of that different rashes. If it looks like a psoriasis, it's not always definitive, but you can't always figure that out.
Definitely with any rashes, you want to consider different contact issues. Do I have this rash because of my laundry detergent? Do I have this rash because of something you're exposing yourself to.
A cream that you're putting on, a lotion, a sunscreen block, something like that.
Honestly, those are the most common causes of issues like that. Toxic exposure, not just topically can cause rashes.
Remember, your skin is an organ of detoxification, so many times you'll break out of the rash because you're exposed to something you breathed in.
So, I've had patients that bought a new piece of furniture, and what would that be? A new piece of furniture.
Well, almost all furniture by law is made with fabric that's heavily sprayed with chemical flame retardants, fire retardants.
Fire retardants, chemicals, you could be highly sensitive to. I had one doctor just years ago called me his, I don't remember the total story,
12 year old son's, I remember the symptom pattern that was going on with 12 year old son. The distance testing on him came up fire retardant.
I said, I don't know, it's coming up fire retardant. Maybe this is totally wrong, but that's what's coming up in the doctor said, oh my gosh, we bought a brand new couch three months ago, and he's been sleeping on that couch.
All they did is change where he was sleeping. It is a symptoms one way. So, yes, exposure to chemicals is a huge thing.
So, look at, you know, you're going to put on your Sherlock Holmes hat a little bit and start digging into where am I exposed to different chemicals?
Is it in the yard? Is it people sprayed stuff? Is it things I breathed in? Is it things I've eaten? There's just food sensitivities can cause that. It just goes on and on and on.
So, short of doing, you know, some more extensive functional medicine tests, you know, that's the thing I would start with.
I was going to, we've done all that. We can't figure it out. What would I do next? I would look at gut issues. I would start with Syrex Array 2 and see if I have got permeability issues because that's very cobbled with skin thrashes.